In 2006, Jennifer Carpenter was an up-and-coming
actress whose luck changed virtually overnight
when she booked the second lead on Showtime's
breakout serial killer drama Dexter.
Carpenter frequently stole the spotlight from
star Michael C. Hall with her impassioned
turn as Dexter's foster sister Debra, a homicide
detective whose caseload often overlapped
with her duplicitous brother's own crimes.
It's been almost seven years since Dexter's
divisive finale episode aired, and fans are
still wondering if Carpenter's Debra got the
send-off she deserved.
As for Carpenter herself, she's maintained
a lower profile recently, but she's more than
kept herself busy since leaving Debra and
Dexter behind.
Like so many actors in and around Hollywood
over the past decade or so, Jennifer Carpenter
eventually found herself with a ticket to
ride the Marvel money train, but it wasn't
quite of the first-class nature.
She only got to contribute her voice to the
ever-expanding Marvel-verse through the animated
project Avengers Confidential: Black Widow
& Punisher.
In the 2014 anime film, it's Carpenter's golden
pipes - and not Scarlett Johansson's - you
hear as tough-as-nails Natasha Romanoff.
"Evening, Castle.
What have you got there?
Friend of yours?"
Marvel's Black Widow isn't the only big-time
comic book character Jennifer Carpenter has
voiced since her days on Dexter.
Her second turn in the animated comic book
movie world found her voicing Selina Kyle,
best known as Gotham City's Catwoman, in Warner
Bros. and DC Comics' lavish, 19th-century
reimagining of the Dark Knight saga, Batman:
Gotham by Gaslight.
Released to largely positive reviews in 2018,
Gotham by Gaslight was adapted from the 1989
graphic novel of the same name, itself the
first official offering from DC's "Elseworlds"
imprint.
Both the book and the film feature Bruce Wayne
defending the streets of a gloriously steam-punky
Gotham as a Victorian-era Batman, eventually
facing off against the infamous killer Jack
the Ripper.
But Carpenter hasn't shied away from performing
in front of the camera as well.
Since leaving Dexter behind, the actress has
sought out similar success on the small screen.
That search ultimately led the actress to
the hyper-competitive realm of network television,
where she's delivered strong work in largely
forgettable dramas.
The first of Carpenter's post-Dexter TV roles
came on the short-lived dramedy Limitless,
which was based on the Bradley Cooper-starring
movie of the same name.
That flick found Cooper tripping the life
fantastic after ingesting a wonder drug that
enabled him to utilize the full potential
of his brain.
The television adaptation, which was produced
by Cooper and Joker director Todd Phillips,
followed a similar set up.
This time, however, the "gifted" man is out
to make the world a safer place, and Carpenter
portrays the FBI Agent tasked with helping
focus the man's energies on solving crimes.
"You will have plenty of stuff to go through
in the morning."
Carpenter's next television venture found
her playing the other side of the law as a
traitorous former CIA Agent forced to team
up with the FBI to help track down their most-wanted
spy.
Titled The Enemy Within, Carpenter's timely
espionage drama had the look of a winner when
it hit the air in 2019, but tragically never
found its audience and was cancelled after
airing just 13 episodes.
The actress seems to have had better luck
on the big screen, having found a patron of
sorts in cinematic rabble-rouser S. Craig
Zahler, whose modern B-movie marvels include
Brawl in Cell Block 99 and 2019's disturbing
dirty cop caper Dragged Across Concrete.
In the hyper-violent Brawl in Cell Block 99,
Carpenter plays Lauren Thomas, the wife of
Vince Vaughn's Bradley Thomas, a retired boxer
whose life of crime lands him behind bars
at the Redleaf Correctional Facility, where
his troubles only grow more intense.
Throughout it all, Carpenter stayed devoted
to the madness while breathing necessary life
into a character that's not quite three-dimensional.
She did the same in Dragged Across Concrete,
bringing a refreshing humanity to tortured
young mother Kelly Summer, who serves as a
smaller character against leads Mel Gibson
and Vince Vaughn, who play a pair of cops
suspended after assaulting a suspect.
In late 2019, Carpenter was cast in the film
A Mouthful of Air, alongside Amanda Seyfried
and Britt Robertson.
The film is an adaptation of Amy Koppelman's
novel of the same name, and centers on a new
mother and children's book author who uses
her own imaginary world as a means of escape
from postpartum depression.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.